wir haben ja schon festgestellt dass
manche garten heck videos ziemlich
sinnlos sind und das ärgert mich immer
wenn solche videos millionen aufrufe
haben aber die sachen die da drin
gezeigt werden überhaupt nicht
funktionieren es gibt aber ein paar
ziemlich coole garten hacks die wirklich
funktionieren und die zeigen wir euch
heute
und zwar kann man wenn man junge
pflänzchen vor frost schützen möchte
entweder jetzt im herbst oder dann im
frühling einfach ein marmeladenglas
nehmen dass über das junge pflänzchen
stülpen und so hat man ein kleines mini
treibhaus gebaut und schützt die
pflanzen gleichzeitig auch noch
verstecken ob zum nächsten heck den habe
ich von jackie und zwar könnt ihr wenn
ihr wühlmäuse im garten hab das ist ja
echt eine plage aber dann könnt ihr
einfach mal einen stab in die erde
stecken da eine alte plastikflaschen
überstülpen und dann wird die vom willst
du hin und her gerüttelt der schall
überträgt sich auf den boden und dass
wir den louis und hoffentlich so offen
denke dass die beete in ruhe lassen aber
denk dran wir sind wirklich hartnäckig
und man muss da immer unterschiedliche
methoden einsetzen um die wirklich
effektiv aus dem garten vertreiben zu
können aus klopapierrollen kann man
richtig einfach angst doch töpfchen was
will dafür einfach an einer seite 4
schnitzereien die laschen um falten so
dass da ein boden entsteht und dann
könnt ihr da direkt einsehen und wenn
ihr dann auch noch die passenden pflanze
braucht um eure aussagen zu beschriften
dann könnt ihr dafür zum beispiel
joghurt becher klein schneiden oder alte
plastikabfälle das funktioniert richtig
gut wenn man die mit einem edding
beschriftet dann kann die schrift auch
nicht abgewaschen werden gemüse wie kohl
oder lauf sind ja sehr empfindlich weil
es viele viele schädlinge gibt dies auf
die abgesehen haben und deswegen bei
euch die zum beispiel immer unter seinem
kultur schutznetz an damit die
schädlinge da gar nicht erst rein kommen
und dafür ist es super praktisch wenn
man sich solche böden baut wo man dann
das netz zu überspannen kann oder im
winter zum beispiel auch den winter
fliesst so dass die gemüse ein bisschen
eingemummelt und vor frost geschützt
sind und diese bögen kann man sich ganz
einfach selber bauen aus
elektroinstallations- rohren da nämlich
immer die die innen drin so einen
aluminium kern haben weil die sehr viel
besser mit frost zurechtkommen als die
die nur aus plastik sind dann schneidig
die einfach in stücke und bieten mir
daraus meine bögen machen den kleinen
metallstab in die erde da kommen die
dann drauf und so kann man sich ganz
einfach mini tunnels selber bauen
wusstet ihr dass ihr wenn ihr kartoffeln
pflanzen wollt die kartoffeln einfach
einmal in der mitte durchschneiden könnt
und dann habt ihr zwei unterschiedliche
pflanzkartoffel dabei ist es ganz
wichtig dass ihr darauf achtet dass jede
der hälften auf jeden fall noch augen
hat das sind diese dinger hier weil da
später die triebe raus wachsen und dann
müsst ihr die schnittflächen doch
abtrocknen lassen bevor ihr die pflanz
der mit der kleine kein reinkommen
ansonsten könnt ihr die auch meine asche
tunken das hat den gleichen effekt aber
dann könnt ihr aus einer pflanzkartoffel
gleich zwei oder drei machen wenn ihr
viele schnecken in ihrem garten habt
dann könnt ihr aus dem alten
joghurtbecher ganz einfach einen sehr
effektiven schnecken schutz basteln wenn
ihr wissen wollt wie das funktioniert
dann schaut mal da drüben vorbei
ansonsten geht raus macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns am
samstag um 10 uhr neues video tief